Guys, when's the last quickie you had? Sean? Well, probably yesterday. What do you mean by quickie? Well, that's... What do you mean by probably yesterday? Welcome to Smartless. Lattice. Smart. Lattice.
Smart. Lattice. JB, JB, let's just get into your hairs midway short. Yeah, yeah. I know, look at that. And tomorrow morning the rest of this garbage comes off and I'll just be into stubble and then I'll be into a mullet. And you already cut a little bit of your hair a little bit.
Yeah, so I'm gonna keep the party in the back and pull in some business on the sides and the top. And that'll work for two days. And then we go backwards 20 years. So I'll go back into like your level, your short hair, Sean, and clean shaven. Like a Michael Bluth, you're gonna go back to a Michael. I'll go back to a Michael Bluth or a Marty Bird
or really every other part I've ever played in my life. How dare you, how dare you. Yeah, the acting stretches have not been significant in my career. Not true. Will you be sad to see the change go? Yeah, a little bit, but I gotta tell you, I don't know how women do it with the long hair and the showering, you know, like,
it's always tangled in your face, and it takes you 20 minutes to wash your hair. It's just a nightmare. It's been coming up on a year since you've been growing that hair out and stuff. I mean, this is like a- Longer than a year. Yeah, so this is a big, this is gonna be a big departure.
Yeah, I can't wait. My daughters are excited to be done with my nonsense. My wife is not happy about it. So I saw your wife last night. Yeah, that's what I heard. Yeah, and then she said to me, she's like, I like it, because my hair's getting a little bit longer than I usually have it.
Yeah, it's very long now. And she goes, I like it that way, and then our friend goes, no, it's too long. It's, yeah, I don't like it like that. And then also proceeded to tell me that I was a little overweight. Oh, this is another guest at the party? Yeah, so this is the host.
And I'm like, okay, well, that feels great. I think you look beautiful. Yeah. You actually look a little thin to me. That's what I said. Yeah, I'd like to fatten him up a little bit. You look beautiful. You actually look a little thin to me. That's what I said. I'd like to fatten him up a little bit. You look thinner. Sorry, I don't mean to talk to you about,
I just don't like to do some sort of like, concubine that's just coming. Can you hold please? I'd like to plump you up a little bit before our session. I love. Sean, how are you feeling? You're still in New York. we still haven't seen each other. I know, but.
It's as if we don't like each other. But if, when you're done with your show. This is my plan, I was gonna say this, but I'll say this. I was gonna say, please come over. Thursday night, let's do it, because I'm getting in Wednesday, let's do a Thursday night dinner, either at Seanie at your apartment or somewhere.
That would be great. Yeah, great, because I'm furious that I have now, you know, I'm finishing on Wednesday after seven or eight months on this thing. Well, and not including the prep, a month of prep. Well, no, that includes it. And my wife, because she's smarter and kinder about our friends than I am,
has forced me to not come home after eight months of being away and stay an extra five days to go see our friend who's opening in a new play. And so I have to sit here and just kill five days of my life waiting for this. But that's when you come over and we'll take care of you. But I mean, I don't think our friend would care
if I come see it like in a month or in two months. Yeah. Right? Is opening night that big of a deal? No, but yeah, it's nice. We're all gonna go. It's gonna be nice. You're doing it for somebody else. Yeah.
But why didn't we all do it later? What do you think your face is doing right now? It probably looks pretty pissed off. That's just gravity. Yeah, but it's the good, nice thing to do. We're gonna have dinner, the three of us, then we're gonna do Jack, JB, we already talked about it this weekend.
So you're gonna kill some time for me. You're not gonna be stuck out on Long Island, you're gonna stay here in the city? No, I'm not coming, I'm not gonna go to Long Island. I'm just gonna be in the city the whole time. Oh, great. Yeah. All right, so then I've got you until the kids
and the wife get here on Friday. Exactly right. And Sean is still in town. Yeah. And I'm still not seeing him. We worked it out. We worked this out. We have it all laid out for you when you come over.
If you're listening out there and you wanna grab a lunch or something, just let us know. I was walking down the street the other day and this girl had her earbuds in and she goes, Oh my God, Sean Hayes. I go, yeah, she goes, you're really in New York just like you said you were on the podcast.
I mean. I don't make it up. Now, all right, here comes a guest. It's been 50, no, 24 minutes this guest has been waiting with my bad technological problems. All right. Today, for your listening pleasure, I have brought to you an actor, a writer, a producer,
an academic, an activist, and a cellist, all in one. A cellist? A cellist, all in one. A cellist. A cellist, yeah. Wow. For me, his ability to deliver social, political, and religious commentary, wrapped up in side-splitting comedy, is completely unmatched, making him one of the most effective and valuable satirists we have in this world.
He starred in multiple movies, both comedic and dramatic, worked with some of our fanciest directors, been nominated, won multiple awards, and he is my absolute favorite person to see at a party. Guys, the sneaky handsome, devastatingly funny, Cambridge smart, yet always cheeky, Sasha Baron Cohen. Oh, for God's sake, look at him go!
Sasha, I'm so sorry for the delay. No, don't worry. I mean, a man of your... I'm not, now I don't feel so bad knowing it's Sasha. Now that it's Sasha, it's okay. Will, let me butter him up and then you take him down. Okay, thank you. It's ridiculous that I've left somebody of your stature
waiting this long, I apologize. Come, come. Please. It's an honor. It's an honor to be 114th. Yes. I'm very much. You're deep.
You're deep. You should have been on earlier. Yeah. Yeah. When you bury, when you do, when you do like, when you have like a big act, right, you don't have the marquee act first. You have the opening act. You make people wait.
You have them 114th. You have 230 opening act. It's deeper than that. Hey, Sasha. Sasha. Hey, how are you? Nice to It's deeper than that. Hey, Sasha. Sasha. Hey, how are you? Nice to see you. Nice to meet you, Sasha.
I don't think I've ever met you. Have we never met? That seems bizarre. I'm sorry. Lovely to meet you. Lovely to meet you, too. We'll keep your knees bent on that one. Sasha, you're in Los Angeles or New York?
I'm in Morreira in French Polynesia where I live now. Oh, wow. This isn't a bit. Yeah, no, it's a bit. Would you ever live in French Polynesia? Because that sounded great. You know what? I actually considered, I looked into it very thoroughly.
Jokes aside. Truly. That particular spot. During the pandemic, yeah, during the pandemic, we knew we were going to move, but we were looking somewhere in the southern hemisphere because we knew that the flu... The virus doesn't last as long in the southern hemisphere. The northern hemisphere, the virus was crazy strong.
I think at that point, it was somewhere in the southern hemisphere, and so we had missed the virus. We were advised by someone at Johns Hopkins who I happened to be. Happened to know. And so we looked into French Polynesia. I looked carefully into Tahiti.
It was interesting. Yeah. There's a bilingual school. Yeah. You know, there's beaches. Have you been to Bora Bora? Have you been to the Brando? Have you been to Moriah? Have you been to the Brando? Have you been to Moriah?
I have been to Moriah, and I've been to, I've not been to the Brando. It's pretty great. And I have been to Bora Bora. Where's the Brando? And I can tell you everywhere else that I've visited as well. This sounds like real elite fuck off conversation, but.
No, no, no, quite right. Let's discuss the best totems. No, but you know, listeners, I always thought Tahiti was like, you know, on the edge of the earth. It's only three hours past Hawaii for anybody on the West Coast, you know? So people on the West Coast, they go to Hawaii all the time.
It's like Florida for the people in New York. Yeah, it's eight hours. But it's just three hours past that. And you're very familiar with it, Jay, because you actually worked there. So the first time you went down there. Yeah, I did. To fulfill an obligation.
Couples retreat, yes. Yeah, yes. By the way, I am happy to discuss French Polynesia. At length. Till the end, yes. Actually, I was in a shark attack there once. You were? I don't know, I was kind of feeding frenzy.
You were in one. In Morreia. I went shark were in a feeding frenzy. You were in one. In Morreia. I went shark diving in Bora Bora. Yeah. Did you, so is that where it came from? Did you go down to dive with sharks and things got a little hot? In those days, I think it's illegal now,
they used to do something called shark feeding where I was doing my PADI license and then. That's how you get certified as a scuba diver listener, Tracy, PA is from here. Exactly, exactly. And Sean, yeah. And what happened? And then, yeah, the guy I was with,
some French instructor, had basically said, we're going to feed some sharks, and then he puts on a kind of chain mail hand thing. Obviously we're underwater, and he just said, be near me, and it was just me and him. And he basically breaks open a sardine, I remember it. And then I remember seeing the droplets of blood. And then within literally two minutes
there were 12 sharks around. No way. And then he pulls out this bag, this tuna head, and he's got a chainmail hand on, chainmail kind of glove on, and they start eating the thing. And it's really interesting and I'm there opposite. Then they get carried away. hand on, chainmail kind of glove on, and they start eating the thing. And it's really interesting, and I'm there opposite.
Then they get carried away, and there's a feeding frenzy, and you can't see anything. And he's looking at you with eyebrows high, like isn't this fine? He's not looking at me. His glove gets knocked off, and his regulator gets knocked out of his mouth, and then he leaves. He needs some air.
He goes up and leaves me alone with the 12 sharks. That are, and I can't see a thing. Does he put up one finger like, I'll be right back. No, nothing, it was literally nothing. I went down there with a guy, he put a tuna head in his wetsuit, right in the front of his wetsuit, in order to have all the sharks, it was a big group of us. And, I mean, this was planned.
And he said not to worry about it. And we did a little bit and then it was okay. And you can see in their eyes that they're not interested in you. Like, you know, sharks are always scary when your head's kind of just above the water. You don't know what's going on below. But once you get under and you can look at a shark,
look at you and then kind of swim away your fear of sharks goes away instantly I highly recommend it that did not happen when the sharks knocked the regulator out of his mouth Knocked the gloves off and he swam away Sean You told me once you walked out of a Ralph's with like 12 cans of tuna in your pants, right? in your pants, right? Is that a true story? Did that happen or was that just true? That was like a dream come true, yeah. But Sasha, you sound like that was a surprise
that it went awry. I was, and I basically started hyperventilating. I mean, this was my second time diving in my life. Yeah, but I mean like. And then actually the guy put his regulator back on, put the glove back, because he'd left me alone. Went back down and then the first shark went to attack him and he punched it in the nose.
I mean this is not good for animal rights lovers out there. No, but that's what you're supposed to do. He's defending himself, that's okay. Yeah. I mean if the shark is eating you and you're just going, no, I didn't want to punch it in the nose. You can hurt me, I don't want to hurt you. Yeah, give me a break. No, you're just going, no, I didn't want to punch it in the nose. You can hurt me, I don't want to hurt you. Yeah, give me a break.
No, you're allowed. Are you sure that the shark wasn't just coming to him for more sort of that blood? He wasn't trying to bite the guy, was he? I don't think so. I think they were just in a frenzy. He headbutted the big shark. Did they interview the shark after? Did they get a picture?
He headbutted him. He headbutted one of the sharks. The lemon shark, which I think was kind of about 12 feet long. He headbutted one of the sharks. The lemon shark, which I think was kind of about 12 feet long. He headbutted that shark. No, of course you have to. In France we headbutt the shark. Afterwards I did go up to him and I said, has anyone...
In the end, basically he came over to me, checked my oxygen, and I completely run out of oxygen. And then we did some emergency procedure. Where you take his regulator, he puts it in your mouth and then we did some emergency procedure. Where you know, you take his regulator, you know, he puts it in your mouth and you put yours in his mouth. He's like, we both have to get in the same wetsuit, don't worry, it's fine. This is how we regulate. This is a very long ruse.
We're both in this, we go down below. This hasn't wrecked your love of scuba diving though, has it? No, no, no, I went back the next day. I did say to him, I said, has anyone ever got hurt on any of your dives? And he said, two people have died. No way, for real. Seriously. But it was painless.
Yeah, he was a cave diver. Those guys are completely crazy, and he basically missed the fun of, and the thrill of cave diving. I think scuba diving is like, scuba diving is the most magical thing I've ever done. I would love to do it more and more. But what if you said, have anybody ever done,
and he goes, yes, two people, and you said they, like in a cave, where he goes, no, I murdered them. This was above, this was not in the water. No, the night before I murdered them in the room, I strangled them. Do you do a lot of that stuff, Sasha? Like do you thrill seek?
Are you a thrill seeker? Not really, no, no, no, no. Have you ever skydived? Would you? I have not, I would not. Have you, have you? I was a week away from it and then I canceled it because I said to myself,
okay, what do you think you'd feel at the end? And then I realized all I would feel is relief. And then I thought, well, I've just had my first kid and I shouldn't be doing things that I'm excited about having gotten away with it. You know, like no longer should I be doing things I get away with. And so I stopped.
I said, you know what, I don't wanna do it. And none of you guys have done it. Would all three of you do it? I did the simulation thing, but not really. What do you mean, the fucking little fly suit at Universal Studios? You get the two with the air? No, that doesn't count. Does it count?
So, Sasha Baroncon, let's drop the Baron, huh? Just to make me even more Jewish. Well, let's... But wait, Baron is not a part of the last name, is it? Is that your middle name? It's part of the last name, yeah. Oh, not a part of the last name, is it, is it just, is that your middle name? It's part of the last name, yeah. Oh, it's part of the last name, oh, got it. So, Sasha, your blend of comedy and,
for lack of a better term, education, as I said in the intro, I find personally so admirable and like you make the medicine go down super easy for ding-dongs like me in the stuff you shine a light on, not only just on issues, but also sort of ethics and bigotry and et cetera, et cetera. Where does that come, well, I kind of know where it comes from, but tell the audience, like, when did you figure out
you could blend your social awareness with your comedic talents? Firstly, thank you very much for that description. Let's take it down. It was lovely, I could spend all day on that. But please don't. Ha ha ha! I think it was the first time... Actually, the second time I did Borat.
So basically, Borat was created... I was doing like a satellite TV show called F2F. Well, I was the host of it. It was a discussion show for teenage kids. We talked about everything. And it talked about teen topics. called F2F, where I was the host of there. It was a discussion show for teenage kids. We talked about everything. And it talked about teen topics. And I wanted to be a comedian.
And so I would go and pre-record characters that I could throw to. And basically, I went out once, and I had a kind of skateboarding character that was an early form of Ali G and then I basically saw some real skateboarders and the guy I was with, this sort of old director from E-Link Studios who had lost all his money and was working on this really shitty satellite TV show, I said look, those guys look like me. I go, do you think I should talk to them?
And he said, 100%. So I go over to these guys, and I'm basically on my skateboard, and I'm playing this early Ali G character, and they thought I was real. And after about three minutes, I said, guys, you know, I'm not, you know, I'm not real. This is just, you know, I'm playing along. They were completely freaked out.
And then I, a tourist bus came, I jumped on the tourist bus, I commandeered it, I started rapping, got off the bus, went into a pub, started- What year was this, Sasha, what year was this maybe? This was, I think, 1995 or four. Okay. Anyway, I basically go into a pub, I start break dancing, they call the police,
I go into some big business, I claim that my dad's upstairs and he's the CEO, they call security. We run back to this live TV show, I run, they put on my normal clothes, and this guy, this legendary guy, who's an editor at Ealing Studios, is editing while I'm on air.
This is the days of pneumatics. This is, he's like cutting, you know, every time he's losing forefront, and he's adding music, and this guy was the kind of legendary guy. And I'm cutting to this stuff, and it's me with real people, so it was the first time that it was a comic character
with real people. And you realize that you could Trojan horse some of the social commentary inside a comedy, yeah? You're right, I'm not really answering your question at all. This was like the first time I ever did characters in the real world. Because you weren't doing that shit yet. Like even Ali G, you weren't really,
early on Ali G, you weren't really making commentary. You were just fucking with people. Yeah. Early on. Well, but you were exposing sort of the low brow perspective on certain things that deserve a high brow analysis. Yeah? I think in a way, Ali G was kind of a undermining of the establishment.
It was essentially saying, okay, these people that run society, they are completely out of touch with society so much that they will believe that this guy is real, despite him asking the most absurd questions ever. Can I tell you, Sasha, I think I've told you this, and JB, you might know this, but I don't mean to speak ill of the dead.
But they don't give a shit. You're not going to criticize Hitler again, are you? No, I told you I wouldn't ever. Remember, you made me, I signed a... I made a promise to him. Yeah, stop it. I was in tears, yeah. You were an absolute wreck.
I was furious. I was weeping. It's one of the weirdest positions. I was weeping at the Vanity Fair party when you were... It's not a position you think Sasha would have, but boy, no, was years ago, right after it aired, and I want to say about 2003, 2004, something like that, you were still doing LAG at the time, it was before Borat.
And I was at a party with, because he was on Arrested Development, with James Lipton. Jason, you were there too. And I had just seen it, and I said to James Lipton, I go, oh, I saw you on LAG, and I said, God, that was so funny. The actor studio guy? The actor studio guy, yeah.
And he was on Arrested Development. He played the warden of the prison. That's great. Warden Gentles? Gentiles? Yeah, yeah, that's right. I think that's right. And it's a really funny bit to have a Mr. Warden, right?
And the whole time he's really just trying to get them all to mount a play, like a musical. But he says, I said, yeah, I saw your analogy, God, that was so funny, and he goes, I knew when he came in, I knew that it was a bit, and he went on this whole thing, and I just watched it, and I'm thinking like, no, you didn't. No, he had absolutely no idea,
because he took me off camera after we'd finished the interview, back to the other room, and so, you know, I was still in character, he completely believed who I was. And I think he showed me like a painting of a naked woman. Yes, is that possible? It's of his wife, yeah it is, yeah.
Yeah, and he goes, that is my wife. Which you wouldn't do if you thought, and I was like, young man, yo, she is, man, I would bone that, yo. Somebody else, wait, you know how I know that? Somebody else, Sasha, has told me that very same thing that he turned back and said, this is the naked picture painting of my wife.
There we go, you verified the story. That is fact checking. We have just fact checked. There you go. We've established me as a reliable witness. And that started the classic line from Borat of, it's my wife, right? Yeah, it's my naked wife James Lipton we it was beautiful by the way. She was beautiful. She was classically if we use those kind of ways to categorize women Sure, what does it mean? Of course?
We'll be right back And now back to the show. At the beginning when I asked you about the risk taking, I was like, would you do anything else other than swim with the sharks or whatever? And you said, no, absolutely not. We talk about skydiving. I just realizing, what you do is so high risk.
So risky, oh my God. So it's like that must fulfill some kind of like, thrusting you. Yeah, the fear, like you love that kind of rush of like, you're about to get caught. Right, you're not doing that as much anymore, correct? Is that because you're just sort of like older and wiser and you don't want to get hit or run anymore?
Well, the last... Sorry, sorry. Yeah, no, end of question. Interrupted slightly. I thought I was waiting for that sliver. You threw me a line. I went in a little early. No, I can go on. And then there was an orb. Thank you for that.
Then there was an orb. Well, the last Borat movie, there was quite a lot of that stuff and actually, I mean, we did, there was a scene at a gun rally which was, got quite hairy. I remember reading about that, yeah. Yes, it was, you know, I mean, people were semi-automatics and automatics in the audience and it was a militia, unfortunately, that had organized it that then didn't take it very well. And I was singing a song called The Wuhan Flu. That's right.
Everybody what I gotta do. I can't even remember it. I mean, where does the fearlessness come from though? I mean, fortunately. Well, there, I'll tell you the truth with that scene because we knew that there were going to be, you know, basically it was a gun rally, and everyone was talking about something.
It was in the middle of COVID, we were the only movie shooting, and so, you know, my security said, listen, you need to have a bulletproof vest on. And so I put on the bulletproof vest, and I said, they go, that's fine for pistols. And they said, I go, once if somebody shoots the, you shoots the semi-automatic?
And, you know, it's not just one person. So they built, so I was singing on stage, so they built an amplifier that was pretty much bombproof. So they basically said, you know, if people start really shooting with the semi-automatics, go behind the amplifier and you'll be safe. Jesus! It's unbelievable. And so the thing is, you know, you're in the scene, I'm on stage, and you know, you have this kind of conflict between, you know, I'm terrified, and then you always have, I need
to get the scene. So you want to, so I was doing, you know, the same verse again, because I felt I hadn't got a good take of it. People were getting more and more, you know, they realized at some point that it was me on stage. There was somebody actually undercover from Black Lives Matter had infiltrated this gun rally. And basically they recognized me and word spread that it was me. Black Lives Matter had infiltrated this gun rally.
Yeah. And basically they recognized me and word spread that it was me. And then people started trying to storm the stage. Right, because they realized they were getting clowned. Yeah. And obviously they all had guns. And then, but I'm trying to get the scene and obviously to do as many different takes
and eventually they did storm the stage and actually somebody pulled a gun. And luckily I had a very good bodyguard at the time who managed to... Make a bullet. Yeah, he's dead but he gave him such a beautiful funeral. That's why you said at the time. Yeah, he was such a, he went away so well.
He had such a beautiful and reasonable funeral. No. It's funny you mention reasonable because I was going to say as part of this and the situation you describe, you have to deal with a lot of people who some might consider to be unreasonable, to be extremists in certain ways. My question is, when you deal with all these people and you're revealing all this or pulling back the sort of the covers on all this kind of shit,
do you ever have a moment where you go, you know what, this person is kind of a good person. They're just really, they've just gotten off on the wrong path. Or misinformed. I'm sure some of them are despicable, yeah, but just some are misinformed, but actually at their heart, they're kind really, they've just gotten off on the wrong path. Or misinformed. I'm sure some of them are despicable, yeah, but just some are misinformed, but actually at their heart they're kind of good people.
Yes, I mean, on the last movie as well, there were these two guys I spent three days in a house with, called Jim and Jerry. And they were... Wait, this is Bruno, right? No, this was Bull Rat 2. Oh, right, right, right. You know, they believe that Hillary Clinton
drank the blood of children and, you know, COVID was a conspiracy and... And that Hillary had killed kids and all. But they were actually... They were nice people. They were good people. They were just... misinformed. And so you suddenly realize they're,
and they were actually feminists because, well, when I was being, when Borat was being a misogynist about his daughter, he was like, they took it upon themselves to teach me that it was important to be respectful to your daughter, and if she wanted to do her own thing, she should do. So they were actually good guys and you suddenly realized,
and it was a surprise, right, because they had those views and you want to dismiss these people as being horrific. And then you suddenly realize that actually any good person, if they're fed a set of ideas and set of information that's wrong can believe conspiracy theories that ultimately lead to horrific stuff. Right? Right?
Well, I mean, you know, we, at the risk of stepping towards political, which we try not to do on this, because God knows people get enough of that shit away from here. Tell me about it. But just on the subject, do you feel hopeful at all that there's a scenario of possibility where those who feel so disenfranchised and aggrieved can be brought into a sense of,
well, actually, I guess we aren't, you know, we needn't be tribalized. We can all kind of get along and work as one. Like, do you see that as a possibility soon? I don't, given the state of the current, you know, internet and information laws, basically. Yeah, that possibly you can penetrate this misinformation and make it healthy.
Well, you're being fed so much stuff that polarizes you. Yeah. If you look at the craziness that is going on in the world, everything has been accelerating since social media came along. So until really, in my opinion, until you actually get laws that, you know, get legislation that curbs the power of those social media companies and says,
all right, actually you can't spread lies like this that kill people or that completely undermine democracy. And you are legitimately educated on this issue of free speech versus, you know, trying to keep the social media sites from being regulated. So my question to you is, what is that difference between, well, free speech should be given to everybody, but you can't yell fire in a crowded theater?
So what is that line and who is the one that can say, oh yeah, this qualifies as you can't yell fire in a crowded theater, so therefore you can't say that? Like who decides what statements get put in that category? I mean these are very big questions, huge. And they kind of vary from country to country. So in England, Australia, and Germany, you have laws about hate speech
and about certain types of misinformation. In America, obviously, you have complete free speech, but it's not up to those- Except for yelling fire. Yes, well, actually, you kind of can at the moment. I mean, the internet companies, because they're not regulated because of this thing called Section 230 230 they can
put out which is a free speech thing right section 230 isn't really about free speech it basically says you can't sue them so once you can't sue a company you know they have no obligation to you know maintain the free speech of the United States in the same way that a restaurant can say, you know what, I'm going to throw you out of the restaurant for saying this or that, or you know, we're having that KKK hood here. So I think the fact, you know, they're saying that they care about free speech,
basically because it's fantastic for their business model. It means that they can have every single person in the world can be on Meta, can be on Instagram, can be on X. They don't care really about free speech. No, look at Elon Musk who consistently talks about free speech. And he'll do that, and then out of the other side of his mouth, he's sort of decrying the government for doing X, Y, and Z, or he's kicking people off, or he's muting them on Twitter.
I actually don't want to talk about this, I don't want to give him any more airtime. The guy's such a, in my opinion, so fucking unfunny, it's crazy, which is I think the most damning thing about, one of, no, a lot of damning things, but the fact is how profoundly unfucking funny he is is so astonishing. And that's why your work and your courage, quite frankly,
in my opinion, is so valuable. And I'd take it, I wish you were back on a weekly show, I'd take it once a week. So thank you for all of that. I think you're right. Yeah, JB, we need to have that sort of, you need to be in there lampooning and really showing, shedding light on the hypocrisy alone
is so fucking jarring, right? Yeah, it's refreshing to- I mean, it must be fun for you when you have those people say, when you put them in that position and then they say the thing that you're like, "'Fuckin' hell, this is unreal.'" Yeah, yeah.
I mean, obviously it's horrific, but you go, you know, while I'm actually in the room, I'm editing the scene as well. So in my head, I'm going, you go, oh, you know, while I'm actually in the room, I'm editing the scene as well. So in my head, I'm going, you know, once they've got the thing, I go, oh, that's great. And now one follow-up question, bang, okay, now I'm going to move on to the next bit. You know, because there's obviously no director there.
Yeah. Where did you, where did, you know, I've always been taken by your... Figure. Your, yeah, your silhouette. You've always been taken by your... Figure. Yeah, your silhouette. It is surprisingly, think more about that. I mean, the show. Tell me more about that.
What do you mean, what do you mean by figure? Stay on that topic, what do you mean? It's surprisingly. It's surprisingly, but I did say sneaky handsome in the intro, I believe. Thank you, thank you. But the, and you did start as a model, but we don't need to talk about that.
You know. More in Wikipedia accuracy. But your ability as an actor is like, breathtaking might be overstating it, but I don't have a better word. I don't know, I don't know. I'm just kidding. But it's like your comedy is never,
your comedy never comes from jokes and you're never making, you know, it's rarely as a pratfall or making faces. It's about your ability to be so convincing with an extremely eccentric character. And yet you can be literally sitting in front of somebody who's super smart and maybe even prime to sort of sniff out some gotcha moments and they still can't tell that it's you, but not even when you're doing those characters, when you're just in films
and dramas and stuff. Like, you didn't take formal training as an actor, did you? I only did one course. I studied with Philippe Gaultier, the legendary clown teacher. Clown, clown school. At l'école Philippe Gaultier. At a clown school. That was it, I did it.
But no, I didn't really train in acting, no. It's just something that you tell us. Does it just come natural to you? What do you? Well, I think, yeah, I think, you know, we did an experiment after, in 2016, that show Who's America came out of me and my collaborator, Anne Hines and Dan Swimer,
we basically said, you know what, let's just create some characters. I've done a movie, it'd been a complete bomb, and I was like, let's take this opportunity to create some characters, and we decided to go, every week for the next 10 weeks, we're gonna create a character, write it, create a fake prosthetic head for it,
and at the end of the week, shoot with a real person, with a character. And I did that for 10 weeks, and there were a variety of crazy characters, some that made it to the show. Six we put in the show. And then I realized basically, what I was able to do is,
once I've got the way the character speaks and once I work out what it looks like and once I work out what the clothes are and I've got a couple of phrases, I can just stick in it. So that was, because that was a couple of weeks in I was like, oh, this is what I can do is I can, you know, they call it inhabiting a character but I actually kind can, you know, they call it inhabiting a character, but I actually kind of, you know, if I've got 30 seconds or whatever, then I can go in it.
Probably there must be something wrong with my brain. No, I think some people, it's just comfortable to them to pretend to be somebody else and they just know how to be super subtle and convincing and authentic and it doesn't trip them up and you're able to stay in it. Well, there's a freedom, but there's a freedom too if you think about it, because a lot of those times when you're shooting,
especially some of the sort of the, whether it's Borat or Brunner or whatever, you've created a character or multiple characters, but the people you're working with are not aware that they're in a scene in the same way, right? So it's much, A, it's difficult because it's complete verite, right? You're actually in their real life, right?
So you've gotta not just convince the audience, you gotta convince the person you're dealing with in the moment that you're real, a real person, right? So you've gotta do that. And there must be a certain, I don't know, like making that leap is tough, I would imagine, like just getting into that. Yeah, what, making it real?
I mean, it's funny, sometimes I get, you know, I'll have a director say, you know, I want you to do a scripted movie, and they'll go, this time you're gonna be playing a real person. Right. And I go, hold on, the other people I play are real people, which is why I'm with Dick Cheney.
Twice as hard. That's why I'm with Dick Cheney for three hours, and he doesn't doubt once that he's with a real person. What about Giuliani? I mean, thank God, you started that. What can you say? Can you say anything? Can you talk about Giuliani? I mean, thank God, you started that. What can you say? Can you say anything? Can you talk about Giuliani?
Yes, yeah, I can, I think, talk about Giuliani. That was amazing. I mean, essentially, you know, that movie, so we were like, why did we bring Borat back? And actually, I've got to thank Kimmel, where Kimmel said, we want you on, it was like the midterms. And he wanted me to do some sketch where basically
I was a kind of Ashton Kutcher type who had been manipulating Kanye West into turning him into a character that was so ridiculous that he would hang out with Donald Trump. And basically I said, I'll do it so long as Kanye will do it. This was years ago. This was 2018, right?
And so I called up Kanye and said, will you do this thing? And he'd already met up with Trump. And I said, will you do this sketch where it says, we're planning out, we're going to create this ridiculous character. And it's going to end up with you in Trump Tower, and it's going to be as if you were playing along. And he said, I love the idea,
but, you know, I need the president to agree. And I was like, Trump? I go, don't, no, no, don't ask him. So, I couldn't do, he goes, no, I love him, and I want you to, I need to ask him. I go, please do not tell him we're doing this sketch at all. So I couldn't do that sketch, and then basically I decided to do Ball Rat.
Actually, I spoke to Chris Rock, is that a name drop? I think so, yeah. Sure, we'll pick it up. It's a kind of name drop. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's a name drop. So I spoke to Chris Rock, world famous comedian and actor,
and he said, why don't you, you know, I was in a rush. Basically I was going to go on air two days' time. They said, just do Borat going door to door. We did Borat door to door, got the mustache out of storage, and then I realized that basically ball rap was just an extreme form of Trump. They had almost identical views. Ball rap was kind of 30 to 40% more extreme with everything. I was like, oh great we can bring it back for Trump. And then I was like how do I infiltrate you know Trump's I go, okay, if he has a daughter who's 15,
wouldn't it be great if Trump had sex with her? And so, originally I was trying to work out how to get this actress in with Trump. We got a close thing for a while, but it was, we spoke to a lot of ex-Secret Service guys, and the idea was like, I would kind of jump out of the wall somewhere. We had like all these plans where, you know, Trump would be in a room, I would be inside the wall.
We would, you know, hollow out a wall, then build it up around me. And then I'd burst out when he was with her. And... Oh, my gosh. An ex-top Secret Service guy looked after with her. And... Oh my gosh. An ex top Secret Service guy looked after the president. And we go, what do you think of this plan? I'm going to be in there. I'll be in there for like five hours.
He said the issue is that Secret Service have a machine that sees if there's anyone else, anyone in the walls. And I go, all right. So I go, what's worse comes worse. They find that I'm there. And what? They pull me out. He goes, no, they shoot you dead. I go, all right, so I go, what's worse comes worse. They find that I'm there. And what, they pull me out. He goes, no, they shoot you dead.
I go, why? He goes, because why else would you be in a, why would there be a living person inside a wall unless they're across the street? I have the assumption that they can't negotiate with a guy like you, they just kill him. So we basically gave up on Trump. Also, you know, we thought at the time
that he was the most protected person in the world. I mean, this was prior to those last unfortunate incidents. But Rudy? But then we found out Rudy was a possibility. A little bit of a softer target. Yeah, but we knew that he was going to be crucial. Yeah. And we kind of researched him.
We found out what he drank, when he started drinking. Was the answer anything? I think there was a particular type of alcohol. But then we heard that he would sweep the room. He had a very senior head of security who would come in and sweep the room. And so we built a kind of fake cupboard inside the wardrobe. So fake back to... There was a wardrobe, if somebody opened it, it would have a fake back to him.
Behind that was me. And so the idea was, you know, I'd just stand in there for, you know, an hour and a half, and then the necessary bit, jump out if he was close to kissing the girl playing my daughter. And anyway, basically, we had a crew member who accidentally put me in the wrong room. And I said, you know, when is, you know,
so I would have to be in position for this to happen. Otherwise, there's no way to get into the room because his head of security would come into the room, sweep the room, sweep every room, and then he would sit outside, so no one could come in with Rudy and her. And I was in the wrong room, and I said, wait a minute, how long till Rudy goes to the room?
And he said, oh, he's on his way there now. And I was like, now? And basically, I ran to the room. And he said, oh, he's on his way there now. And I was like, now? And basically I ran to the room and I literally saw Rudy's leg come around the corner. I ducked into the room, went into the wardrobe, went behind the fake wall, closed it, and then I heard the door open off his security, sweep the room that I was in, and then come out.
So he swept to the room. We did the scene, you know, venture... Oh, by the way, so I'm in there for an hour and a half, and you know, the only way I can communicate with the director was through a cell phone. And we thought of everything. I pick up the cell phone, I'm in the pitch black, and there's 3%.
Oh, wow. An hour and a half. I was like, we did everything. We's 3%. Oh, yeah. You know, now and a half. I was like, we did everything. We've got hidden cameras, we've got the, but we, somebody had not charged the cell phone. So at some point I had to kind of climb out of it and make eye contact with the brilliant actor Maria,
who's playing my daughter, and she's like, Rudy's on the bed, and she's like coming out, looking at me and going, what do I do? And eventually I confronted Rudy. He freaks out, goes out the room, and his head of security pushes me into the room. I'm playing Borat, and Borat is so naive. If he sees a chair, he'll say, what is this machine
with four legs? And suddenly, the head of security has pushed me back into the room going, you're going nowhere, because I had an escape route. So my security guy was going to take me down the escape route, but the head of security pushes me into the room and goes, you're going nowhere, you're staying right here. And I said, this is a false imprisonment.
You are standing on my property and you will leave now and unhand me now. And basically he realized that and read the law. Ran down, ran down the fire escape, got into a car, got to the crew hotel, and then essentially my lawyer says, he found out what we did and he said, okay, you've got to get out the state now. I go, that's ridiculous, why? They go, Rudy, Rudy had called something and I'd met the
manager of the hotel a year onwards in DC. And he said, Rudy had done something. I don't know what he'd called in, but he said, every single type of law enforcement descended on the hotel, shut down the hotel. They confiscated all the equipment, all the crew was stuck in the hotel rooms. And then my security, I had a policeman that I'd hired, he realized that I'd set up Rudy Giuliani, he immediately told Rudy's security where I lived, where I was staying.
Jesus Christ. And so my lawyer was like, get the hell out of New York City now. I was like, that seems a little bit over the top. I called up this other security guy I know, I know a lot of security guys, who runs these kind of detectives, you know, New York and stuff like that. I said, listen, I've been told I have to leave New York State, you know, in the next 20 minutes, because I interviewed someone and I go,
he goes, what did you do? And I go, you know, more like some lingerie and da-da-da, as a politician. I go, he goes, who was it? I go, it was, you know, Giuliani. He goes, get the hell out of the hotel now. So I start texting everyone who I knew outside of New York, I go, hi, how's it going?
Da-da-da. Haven't seen you for a few years. This was the middle of the pandemic. This is when Manhattan was completely empty. You'd go up Fifth Avenue. There was not a car or a person. I go, how's it going? Any chance I could stay soon.
When? 15 minutes. And people are like, you know, people are like freaked out, not responding. Eventually one of them says yes and basically I drive to Connecticut and it was fantastic but you got all the footage and you got your equipment all the footage and then yeah it was interesting it was interesting and we will be right back.
And now back to the show. So Sasha, I would imagine that the thrill of acting and also the sort of the, and the social relevance, political relevance of some of your efforts is thrilling. Does it compare with the the just the pure acting thrill of being in a film that's directed by Martin Scorsese? I mean, that's just one third of what you're doing when you're doing your other stuff. Can you compare the two of them?
Are you drawn towards one versus the other? I mean, I am drawn. I remember the first film I did was Talladega Nights. Yeah, so good. And it was the first trailer I'd been in. Ricky Bobby. And I went in. Ricky Bobby. And basically I remember seeing that there was a bed in the trailer.
And I'd never had a trailer beforehand because we'd always been in the back of a car. I was like, why is there a bed? Somebody's accidentally put a bed in my room. They go, no, that's... I go, what am I going to do with it? Sleep, you know. I was like, why is there a bed? Somebody's accidentally put a bed in my room. They go, no, that's, I go, what am I meant to do? Sleep, you know? And so I felt, wow, this is actually an incredible gig. But, you know, when it's the other staff,
it is, I mean, it's much less stressful. Although, you know, I just did a, I just did this show with Alfonso Cuaron. Yes, let's talk about that. That's coming up on Apple. Well, we had like a 15 minute scene, yeah, with me and Cate Blanchett, they wanted to do in one take. And that became pretty exhausting and pretty...
Do you have a passion for acting, like the fricking craft of acting? Yes, I mean, if it's good, and you're working with an incredible director, then, and you're an incredible director, my friend. I love you so much. No, you are. Can I just say, let's do the remainder of this
about Jason Bay. But yeah, then it is great. But it's in different categories for you, though, yes? I mean, it's not comparable, right? They're different things, yes? No, no, because you're just doing the act. Everything else is how are we going to get into the room? What's the escape route?
Who's that person? That person's looking suspicious. This person doesn't quite believe me. My fake ear is falling off my head. And then your number eight in the thing is I put an act to sing. Yeah, yeah. Now, Sajar, I speak on behalf of millions of people
that are fans of yours, like I am, like huge fans where we're constantly waiting for your next thing, because you're one of the few artists that combine art and politics and have been so successful in all of those improvisational types of whatever you call them, movies where you play these characters. Obviously you can't tell us if you're,
what it is you're working on, but are you, could we expect another character to pop up in a movie soon? Are you excited about that type of thing to do that again? Because from the outside, I can't wait. Short of the straight acting thing with Kate Blanchett. excited about that type of thing to do that again? Because from the outside, I can't wait. I can't wait for those types of things again. The last one became so extreme.
After that gun rally thing that I was talking about, I was essentially on the run, I had a militia kind of following me, and we were going, I was going from safe house to safe house for about four days. That's the movie. Yeah, exactly. By the way, I mean, it's... That was, yeah, it kind of is the movie, because, you know, you finish that song with that militia, you go, oh, that went really well, And then, you know, the escape itself is tough because we're in an ambulance,
we're surrounded by 30 guys trying to pull me out of the ambulance, they pull open the door. You know, I'm struggling. But we can't get enough of that. We can't get enough of that. Yeah, I mean, no one's rec... You know, that's the behind the scenes stuff that, at some point, there needs to be a behind the scenes movie.
We shot, we did have, we've got a bunch of footage over the last 25 years, but yeah, that, I think it became so crazy in the last one that you realize you've, you know, you've gotta be, there's a certain amount of skill and preparation about always gonna be lucky, and at some point, your luck runs out. Your luck runs out.
And then just the practicality of it, because it has been so successful for so long, this type of, again, for lack of a better term, ambush type of thing. Like people know you. They love these films. Millions and millions of people have seen them. You just can't sneak up on anybody anymore.
Yes. Well, I think just the danger element meant that I just didn't really want to do it again. You know, I had to do it for that election. I had to do it. I felt it was like, you know, I was terrified about what's going to happen. Well, let's not come off the gas just yet, okay? Yes.
We're not out of the woods yet, Sasha. Still need you. That's true. You know, I haven't asked you one fucking question and we're done. You have. We're finished with the time. No, I've got all these things all like highlighted and everything.
It's, I apologize to the listener. We haven't done any legitimate journalism here. Let's at least talk about disclaimer and working with Alfonso Cuaron and Apple and Kate Blanchett. I mean, it's well, well, well deserved for your acting talents to be working with these people at the top of the profession.
So have you seen it all the way through, disclaimer? I watched it for the first time in Venice. Yeah. And I mean, no one could believe that I hadn't watched it for the first time in Venice. And no one could believe that I hadn't watched it until then. The embarrassing thing was I was laughing at the jokes that I'm making. There's not many, but it's quite embarrassing. You're at Premiere watching yourself and you're one of the only people laughing at jokes.
And then I was really moved by one of my performances. I was like near-tear. And I realized I'm just a complete narcissist. Just looking, just really moved by my own performance. Wait, it wasn't until Venice this year that you realized that? Wow. I never knew there was a connection between actors in movies and narcissism.
No, I love it. I'll bet it's absolutely stunning. It's a... It's actually excellent. between actors in movies and narcissism. No, I love that. I'll bet it's absolutely stunning. It's actually excellent. It comes out October. Or it came out. When does it came out? When is it?
When's this coming out? October 11th. When's this coming out? Yeah, it came out. It came out October 11th. Yeah. It came out October 11th. It was amazing.
It's incredible. No, I mean, October 11th, the weather was so great that day. Did you know I loved it? It was great. It was fantastic. Sasha, when do we get to, will you be coming back to Los Angeles at any time soon and we can all hang out again?
Yes, I will. I'd love to see you. Like the old days. God damn it, I love seeing you. And Sean, it'd be lovely to meet you in the flesh. I would love that too. I'm around, just give a shout. If you need a place to crash
when you're in trouble in New York again, my place is yours. Great. If you don't mind my militias coming to your door. Yeah. No, are you kidding? What do they look like? You were really, really nice to say yes to this. I know you don't do this a lot. Yeah. No, no, no. I'm awful at it.
The honest truth is I'm very bad at it. Are you kidding? Even though I see you socially. Socially, it's a pleasure, but the slight pressure with the... No pressure. No, this is great. This is fantastic.
You're a world-class... Very muscly. I can see your... I don't know if you're doing this intentionally, but I've seen glutes. Oh, thanks. It's got everything. No, you've been working out, looking very...
Put your arms down. Are you doing this for a reason? This is from my pinup collection. Early short. I think this was my July from my calendar. Wow. Wow, you really actually do look incredible. Prison with Arnett, that's the calendar.
Sasha, thank you so, so, so much. No, thank you. We love you a lot. Please come out to LA and say hi. I love you, no, seriously, so, so much. No, thank you. We love you a lot. Please come out to LA and say hi. I love you. No, seriously, I love you both. Sean, you seem very lovely. He's the best of the three of us.
Miss you, Sasha. Always a pleasure. These two I do love, I do love. We're trash compared to him. Where do you get a love in him? I love you, Sasha. Even though we don't know each other, I love you. You love me.
I feel affectionate. I feel an instant warmth. Oh, he's a little love thing. You love me. I feel affectionate, I feel an instant warmth. Oh, he's a little love thing. Yeah, yeah, very charming and lovely persona. You just want to pet him when you see him. He totally does seem like that, you're right. You're not going to sue me for saying that, are you? Okay.
Okay. Kay Monte Strong on our podcast. Loved it. Thank you, buddy. Thank you and goodbye. Enjoy the rest of your night. Thank you. No, thank you, Ferg.
I can't wait for Disclaimer. Everybody check it out on Apple. Honestly, I would say I thought it was excellent. Yeah, we'll see you at the Emmys on that. I was clever. I hope they put, they should put that on the poster I think it's excellent Personally thought it was excellent. I have seen stuff that I've done. I was like that is bad I loved it and I cried at myself
But it'd be pretty fucking funny to have a quote from one of the stars of the film He's all of them k-blond shit. Okay, Blanchett a guaranteed from one of the stars of the film. All of them. Cate Blanchett. Cate Blanchett. A guaranteed Emmy, two out of four. Cate Blanchett. End of quote. He's fucking great. Kevin Kline.
I am in this. Oh, Kevin Kline's in it too? Kevin Kline's in it. He's actually fantastic in it. I love Kevin Kline. I love him. I'd like to see more from him. All right, enjoy the rest of your night.
All right. Thank you. See you soon. Love to everyone. OK, toodaloo, thank you, bye. Thank you, pal. Bye, pal. Bye, bye. That's a great guest, Jay, that was really, really great.
Sasha, yeah, great job, JB. I just love him. Sasha Baron Cohen, he's fucking funny. He's got great stories. One of the funniest guys, I mean, he's up there with Sean Hayes, Will Arnett, and Will Ferrell in my world. I just like, they just can't, I get in an instant good mood
when I'm with these people. Well, nobody, I was gonna say to him, nobody does, I mean, it sounds so cliche to say it, but it's true, nobody does what he does. Nobody's ever done what he does. No one's got the intelligence, the balls, or the acting talent to do what he does. Yeah, it's like a Peter Sellers.
Which is his hero, by the way. We didn't even get into that. Oh, really? I'm sure. Yeah, that's his idol. It's like a version of that in real life when he goes. But I'm applying it to the real world. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. Right, which is so, yeah.
It's really cool. I never met him before. He just seems so, I'd love to hang out with him. Yeah. He'd like the greatest at a party. I just start to hover and he's eventually got to walk away from me because I just put in too much time. He seems hyper intelligent.
He is. Oh yeah, Cambridge educated. Oh wow, yeah of course. Not a ding dong. Speaking of ding dongs, what's for lunch today, Sean? We're gonna do a French dip. And with French fries. Why is it always something special?
Like it's always got something with sauce or like some kind of like really electric flavor to it. How about just like some sort of sustenance? Aren't you amazed at how fast I know my answers whenever you ask what I had or what I'm going to have? Well, we're cutting into it right now, right? You can probably smell it, right? Where is it?
It's two o'clock in the East Coast. You can probably smell it. Yeah. Is it already? It's just waiting on the table. Where is it from? No, I'm going to, the second I, there's a place, a block away,
I can't remember the name of it. Don't say the name, someone will try to poison you. Yeah, no. I can't remember, but it, a block away, I can't remember the name of it. Don't say the name, someone will try to poison you. Yeah, no, I can't remember, but it's a block away. It only takes a second to get, yeah. It's so good. Wow. It's so good. It's one of the best in the city. You know what I'm gonna have?
What? Nothing. Yeah. Because I have, because I've got this stupid level of discipline about, because of my passion for my character, my strong- I get it, I know you do. I know you're joking, but it's true, and it's very admirable. And-
I'm so tired. It's not a healthy way to do it. I know, I'm tired of being thin. But Wednesday, that's what I'm saying, Wednesday after Wednesday is over, and you wrap your beautiful show, an amazing show that everybody's gonna go ape shit about. Yeah, Thursday, no, Wednesday or Thursday, no.
Yeah, Wednesday wrap, so Thursday our dinner, can it be something super fattening? Yeah. I have to have, so I'm not, because I have lost weight, I'm on a new thing which is it's all about eating more and eating the right thing, and that's what I'm talking about, losing weight unhealthily is not good. You can lose weight and also do it in a healthy way
and look like this or like that. How you doing? So then what am I gonna have Thursday night? Am I gonna have steak? You know, is steak okay? Yeah, a lot of steak and veggies, no starch, no bread, no nothing like that. Why can't you do pizza?
Can you do pizza? You can have a little bit, no. No. No, man. A little bit of starch at lunch, a tiny bit, like a little bit of maybe a sweet potato, a couple bit, like a little bit of maybe a sweet potato, a couple pieces, maybe a little bit of rice like that much. Yeah.
A couple, yeah. You gotta release the valve every once in a while. So you want a little tiny little bite of pizza, Sean. One sheet meal a week, one meal. To keep your metabolic rate going, right? Yeah, one. But it's not about, here's the other thing. It's not fast metabolism or slow metabolism, it turns out.
Hot or cold. And what you need to do to keep your metabolism hot is you need to feed it with the right stuff at the right time of day. I went and saw this guy, unbelievable. Unreal. And he did, we did a blood test. Is it a guy you're dating?
Oh, a nutritionist. We're just seeing each other. He, I mean, I met him right behind, you know the party store on Sunset. Sure. So I'm like, and I hear, shh. He says, I'm going to be in a Corolla. And he, no, anyway.
How many times did he flash the brights? What was the code? Well, it was Morris Code, and I thought he said, help, and it was, can you help me with my pants? He was just a person. He was like a bystander? Bystander? We'll just commit to it. Just do that. Someone's hungry. Try to do it without going up on by this time.
Okay? So the guy... I know that guy you met behind the party. He was just a regular bystander. Yeah, not as good, but... By! By! Byeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armjarff. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.